actually I forgot what I was gonna say
oh sorry did you want to finish your
point I mean I mean after listening to
all of this
I know this might sound crazy
um I saw a tweet you did
um once where you said women shouldn't
be permitted to vote
and yes yes take it away repeal the 19th
yeah yeah so I I saw it you know
and I could see how you would think that
you know I could see how you think but
I've actually spoken with some women
Harold did you say that oh yeah oh yeah
get rid of it no but but really I I
realize this might sound crazy but the
Tweet you said women it should be
illegal for them to vote and I can I can
see how you would think that
but
I've actually had some conversations
personal ones with women
and I now firmly believe that not all
women
are complete morons
that's actually Alpha King rule number
some women
can actually be
pretty smart sometimes
including yourself Pearl thank you well
you are married I'm assuming your wife
is a wonderful woman
she's she's my pride of Joy exactly so
there you go so there are women pearls
Pearl's a great example of uh uh wow
unique one wow thank you oh unique okay
yeah well she's successful entrepreneur
she organized everything here we go no
no no no no no no no I'm not taking him
the iron the ironing one last thing
here one last thing the irony here would
be that someone like Pearl would be
viewed as someone like a far right maybe
but in reality if you look at all her
staff she Embraces uh quite a bit of
diversity in her Staffing so you know
for example she she's created jobs in
this neighborhood she's an employer she
put aside Capital she saved Capital she
built the equipment she took the office
space she built a couple Studios
right she's not counting on a man to
take care of her she's doing everything
all the same as me so can I say
something I'm not doing what pose doing
right now there is some respect no I
don't I don't take nothing away from po
we have been different we have different
opinions so it's nothing towards pill as
a human being and what she does we have
difference of opinion she doesn't have
to respect my opinion I don't have to
respect her opinion or agree let's say
so because just like she said she wants
to take voting away wherever you said
yeah
so for me I find that's the biggest
because only reason why I say
that okay is for example I'm not going
to mention a name because we're not
allowed but during the period that we
went that we've just passed what
countries had the best
rates
all right or the lowest the management
in terms of management were led by whom
were led by who not men and oh you know
you know where this would actually prove
my point
all of the countries that followed that
stuff right because you're talking about
the job yeah yeah do you know push that
women yeah women yes but who created the
the thing was it well that was an owl
I'm not even gonna lie
it's very funny how it's very funny how
when we talk about leadership and
countries that are led by women yes the
the president might be a woman but does
that mean that it is the president that
is
um running the country
you might be right might be wrong so
what you're saying is not facts neither
no but but then you can you can make an
analogy it says that if you were to look
throughout all of human history whenever
you see a woman at the top of anything
there's usually a team of men usually
very competent men helping her to
achieve her goals so we need each other
no no no no no I would say I would say
women need men and men do not need women
oh my yes yeah we need each other
now so when I'm talking about this is
okay I'm gonna clarify what I mean okay
I'm going to clarify when I'm talking
about running Society so making Society
run take out the reproduction like
raising the kids part I don't think we
need women in society for it to run now
I'm going to tell you why because when
you look at all the jobs
that men mainly do it holds the
infrastructure of society for example
I'm quite I like to think of myself as
young and successful but I couldn't do
what I do without this building that was
built by Men by this microphone that was
built by Men by the plump without the
plumbing that was built by men how do
you know about the electricity because
again I'm a I do I do look up numbers
you know what I mean I do I do and and
yes I am I am a numbers I am a numbers
gal and one and if you look up the um
sex makeup in those Industries it's 90
plus percent men and what another
observation I had is all the industries
We complain about are mostly run by
women now I'm not saying there are not
exceptions of why I can't wait I'm going
to go into them in a second I am not
saying there are not exceptions of high
IQ women that that cannot make an impact
right but are they necessary not really
now the industries that that now I'm
gonna I'm gonna give you an example
let's talk about the industries that
women run one I found out in the U.S we
have something called the DMV Driver's
License it is known as being so slow and
inefficient that the last movie about
the DMV they made a sloth play the DMV
person because they're so slow education
we're always whining about education and
how bad the education system is and how
they're indoctrinating children women
run that industry Health Care is another
one I I always hear people complain
about and and the other thing is the how
Healthcare is still roughly 50 percent
men and the highest jobs in those
Industries are still men
fourth part I'm sorry one more part and
then I'm gonna I'll I will let you go
the the thing that when you look at
successful female women you know they do
monetize Beauty
and so we can look at Industries where
women dominate it's really Beauty like
it's social media modeling
um and like selling makeup Kim
Kardashian Kylie Jenner they all
monetize Beauty all right
um yes that that is my case as to why I
do not think we think we need women to
run the infrastructure of society I will
let you go and then I'll let you and
then I'll let you go okay go ahead I
have a question yes but yeah are you
suggesting the Health Care system is not
running well because there's a less
woman taking highest responsibility or
what was exactly what you said I've
noticed I I didn't make a definitive
statement about health care I'm not
going to pretend I know your ins and
outs of your health care I've just
noticed a trend where the industries
that women tend to dominate so one of
those is nursing right although women
um and women dominate Physicians but
they don't I dominate the like brain
surgery like the highest form of
medicine but but but I've noticed a
trend that a lot of the industries that
have a lot of women in them are there's
a lot of complaints about efficiency
for example Healthcare is one I hear a
lot of complaints about health care both
here and in the US I hear a lot of
complaints I have to stop you here
because
complained it exists I've worked more
than 22 decades working Healthcare
System yes our working minister of
Health in one of the very large
countries in the world okay so is a
woman here okay but say as advisor in
consultant Ministry of Health okay we're
researchered we work in many
universities raise a lot of students to
be Midwife and yes and whatever yes
same we had a lot of men we've worked
together there are a lot of men in those
Industries what does it mean that
because men working or women work
women's working in the house I just I
just example that system doesn't work
because of the portion of men and women
no the Health Care System doesn't work
because of the policy that politician
makes and you know at home okay so this
goes back to my women voting okay
because because no no no no but let me
let me let me let me talk yeah yeah so
so I'll give you an example of this goes
who passes those policies if you talk to
politicians which I have because I
wanted to know why the child support
system was so unfair to men so I was
asking why does this stuff like why is
it so biased and the reason is most
um politicians are catering to women
because they have to single women are
the largest voting block
where men tend to stay the same
so like men are much more loyal right
relationships too but also in politics
when men vote this is true when men okay
you don't have to believe it but it is
true okay men tend to stay with their
voting block where women um tend to
switch more women can be bought a lot
more than men and you see this in
marriages you know they they give you
guys free housing women are like we're
leaving the men now this is true look it
up 60s in the U.S they give women free
housing and government handouts and then
they start to divorce their husbands are
you actually comparing societies
systemic oh Lord
statistics
right I'm giving you I'm giving you I
just
this is an opinion so this part is an
opinion right you can disagree
can I say I think what you have just
said is in when you put it in practice
it's almost it makes it easier for a
woman to leave you don't work at the
marriage you don't you don't want to you
don't want to fix things you don't want
to talk about it you don't want to
communicate it's easier to leave
men and women leave but one's paid to
obviously
but back has other things you know so oh
wait I need I need to I need to finish
one part I'm sorry I'm gonna let you go
I'm sorry one more part and I will I
will but but but the other thing is even
in the industries that women work a lot
in men can easily learn those Industries
men can easily become nurses men can
easily become teachers so if all the
women left the work of course tomorrow
what do you talk okay okay build the
building
okay look at Sophie if you think men
learn easy things sorry
um can we please just remember the rules
it's not just about Pros about each
other as well let's stop over talking
each other I know it's hard but we need
to try and okay should should women
be in charge it just really depends on
the women if she's great at soccer
let's let her coach a girls team but
what I let this lady into pink manage a
beauty salon
of course not
it just depends on the position
no no no sorry can you can you emphasize
on what you're saying I don't get like
the point that you made about her
running a beauty yeah I don't get that
it depends on the position as many of
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible